[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est à
marseille il fait un temps complètement
dingue et je profite effectivement bien
d'être dans la cité phocéenne pour vous
annoncer une excellente nouvelle
je fais partie des 50 testeurs officiels
pour tester le nouveau yoga book de
lenovo
on va beaucoup parler pendant les
quelques semaines à venir parce que
c'est effectivement un produit qui est
intéressant c'est un hybride entre
effectivement une tablette un ordinateur
fait partie de cette nouvelle gamme
ingérer de deux produits un peu hybride
qui nous permet effectivement utilisé
comme une tablette d'avoir de la porte
activités mais aussi de mettre comme un
petit ordi est de pouvoir conserver hier
pour du traitement de texte pour pas mal
de choses et je trouve que ça c'est
vraiment super en tant que testeur
officielle pour lenovo
on a un peu le plaisir mais aussi
l'obligation de traiter de différents
points pour pouvoir se rendre compte
effectivement déjà de l'interface est ce
que ce produit est intéressant
la prise en main il ya toute une partie
graphique avec une tablette mais ça on
le verra plus tard en détail donc il va
falloir parler un peu tout ça
regardez si c'est bien bien évidemment
on a absolument emploi et tous les
testeurs aucune obligation de parole on
dit ce qu'on veut soit on aime soit on
aime pas et comme à chaque fois j'aurai
un avis impartial pour effectivement
vous donner mon opinion et je compte
aussi recevoir la vôtre en retour en
commentaire
[Musique]
yoga book productivité on the go
comptable est une boîte au toit qui
était très jolie 1 avec un design qui
est très très très sympa j'aime beaucoup
ce mélange de couleurs blanc et si
orange là qui est qui et réfléchie c'est
très sympa il ya un côté dort
effectivement créés sur le dessus et
yoga book ses classes c'est vraiment ce
classement si on voit qu'effectivement
on a un diplôme points en on né en 1920
par 1200 c'est un petit peu plus gros
que du full hd qui normalement devrait
de 1920 par 1080 mois là j'ai ici le
modèle wifi carbon black en 64 giga à un
cpu intel z8 1554 corps 1to 2.4
gigahertz
je vous disais l'écran en 10.1 pouces
1920 par 1200 et ps la mémoire c'est du
4 gigas lpp ddr3 64 giga de mémoire en
wifi l'ol c'est le windows 10 pro et
puis j'ai eu batterie en 8 500
militaires heures elle fait un kilo 527
fabriqués en chine voilà et tourne avec
un bel intel dessus
[Musique]
donc là on est effectivement sur ce il y
aura beaucoup de lenovo qui
effectivement une boîte qui est très
très simple c'est un beau yoga book avec
windows je ne sais pas si vous voyez
bien là ses marques et yoga book with
windows
il existe aussi une version sous android
si ce 6.0 si je ne trompe pas moi c'est
le windows disque qui tourne directement
dessus
donc quand on enlève ça on va
effectivement pour moi c'est un produit
qui est très qualitatif on ne voit ne
serait-ce que déjà à la volonté de
choisir un papier qui à mon sens nos
papiers recyclés de bonne facture avec
un aspect graphique qui est très sympa
donc pour moi lenovo a vraiment fait un
choix dessus qui est qui est sympa qui
est jolie avec un packaging qu'il n'a
pas à le faire rougir le yoga books
ouvre tout simplement comme un livre
comme ça et à l'intérieur vous découvrez
effectivement cette tablette 2 horno
voire même plus si affinités qui est
présenté ici est en dessous l'accessoire
de recharge est encore en dessous
d'autres accessoires donc on va tirer la
langue est son côté pour la faire venir
le yoga books vient jusqu'à nous on va
le regarder si quelques instants on va
d'abord regarder le contenu à
l'intérieur de la boîte
je vais donc le poser sur le côté à
l'intérieur on se retrouve jeudi juste
un petit coup d'oeil rapide pour pouvoir
effectivement vous dire exactement ce
qu'ils avaient et être sûr de ce que
j'allais vous dire on va avoir ici un
côté 1 pour la recharge la tête un
secteur câble usb avec un format
probablement micro lv1 soupaya d'erreurs
qui se trouve ici
je les ai ouvert tout à l'heure pour les
enlever les blister donc je vous montre
quand même les produits envoyés avec l
adaptateur ici lenovo et de l'autre côté
on va retrouver une autre ouverture pour
récupérer le diable hop avec de l'usb
vous avez ici toute la partie avec l
accessoire qui va servir effectivement
au dessin aux notes mais tout ça on le
verra un petit peu plus tard alors on va
l'ouvrir ici vous allez voir c'est assez
bien foutu bien pensée de la part de
lenovo
on va se retrouver avec cette partie qui
va se mettre sur la table est et qui
sert effectivement à transformer votre
vie yoga book en outil de notes mais ça
on le regarderait après vous avez tous
le quadrillage effectivement de la zone
qui est reconnue avec le stylo pour
pouvoir dessiner sur votre tablette
on regardera ça un peu plus tard et puis
on verra tout ça bien en détail dans une
prochaine vidéo dont la thématique
effectivement sera de présenter ce côté
un peu tablette graphique
on a ensuite à l'intérieur de cette
boîte encore deux compartiments un
compartiment dans lequel on va retrouver
le guide de démarrage et effectivement
on va parler de garanties au niveau de
deux studios gars bouquiaux lenovo dont
plusieurs langues mais bon comment
trouver c'est relativement standard
c'est souvent le manuel qu'on oublie
d'ouvrir un conte regarde à la fin quand
on a un problème
je ne sais pas vous mais moi c'est
souvent le cas le petit outil qui va
nous servir à ouvrir la partie pour
intégrer une carte sim si on le souhaite
parce qu'on peut mettre une carte sim et
on peut rajouter aussi de la mémoire
avec une carte micro sd
si je ne dis pas de bêtises et ensuite
l'outil indispensable et qui a
effectivement qui crée toute la
particularité de ces deux gars books et
notre stylo pas si le terme est exact
les graphismes corrigeront le stylo qui
va vous permettre effectivement
d'utiliser votre avis doit ouvrir votre
votre parti not bad partie des saints
partie tablette graphique avec à
l'intérieur et ça j'ai vu ça et je
trouve ça génial
trois recharges pour pouvoir
effectivement écrire dessiner
tranquillement et voir un petit peu
devant soi avant de devoir le changer
donc voila un petit peu le contenu
principal
de cette ligne a book on va maintenant
regarder un peu plus près comment s'est
fabriqué cette machine en elle-même
comment elle fonctionne et vous allez
voir qu'il ya des choses qui sont
vraiment super intéressantes dedans
voilà la bête là yoga book alors pour
l'ouvrir il y a une petite partie ici à
retirer ces ensembles on l'a on tirait
hommes voilà la machine et quand on
ouvre on voit qu'effectivement que c'est
extrêmement fins regardez c'est presque
c'est aussi fin que le stylo c'est juste
dingue c'est très très très fin et c'est
super bien fait hop là il y à une partie
à l'intérieur
voilà ce qui est vraiment bien dans ce
produit n'est ce pas pour enchanter les
louanges mais ce que je trouve bien et
assez qualitatif c'est les rouages qui
sont faits là je sais pas si on va très
bien à l'écran mais c'est assez dur pour
les manier il faut y aller
on sent la solidité et vous voyez on
sent le produit 1 au final je trouve que
vraiment cette tablette sur guy bouquet
lien fait pour plusieurs raisons parce
que vous avez effectivement un produit
qui est compacte qui se tient
extrêmement bien dans la main un produit
qui a plusieurs facettes
on peut utiliser comme ça qu'on peut
utiliser comme ça qu'on peut utiliser
comme ça et ça c'est génial cette
modularité c'est quelque chose qui était
vraiment attendu alors c'est pas le
premier produit qui fait ça mais par
contre sauf que pour le côté tablette
graphique
c'est le premier produit à faire ça et
ça c'est vraiment extrêmement
intéressant on peut le poser comme on
veut on peut en faire ce qu'on veut et
il n'y a rien à dire se produit en tout
cas en termes de prise en main
d'ouverture j'ai juste de jeter un oeil
dessus je trouve que il est plutôt bien
fait
ça fait quelques jours maintenant que
j'utilise la tablette le yoga book de
lenovo et je dois reconnaître que
franchement c'est plutôt pas mal
la première impression la prise en main
est cool la tablette
eh bien je suis pas un graphiste donc
tout ce qui va être effectivement des
fonctions graphiques ne l'utilisent pas
j'ai eu un petit peu de mal au début à
me faire aux claviers
parce que c'est peut-être plus petit que
le clavier de mon macbook pro au niveau
des touches je suis habitué donc là je
me suis retrouvé sur un truc à pianoter
bombay doit aller un peu d'espoir sur la
mauvaise touche au final on s'y fait
plutôt bien
la taille de l'écran est correct par
rapport à quelqu'un qui est habitué un
écran 15 pouces
on y passe quelque chose de ridicule on
est sur un petit écran par contre pour
tout ce qui va être je dirais la gestion
de la gestion des commentaires ce qui
nous concerne faire du traitement de
texte allait travailler sur le club a
géré tout mon travail en ligne tout ce
qui est connecté ça va ça va très bien
une fois de plus je le dis je suis pas
graphiste j'ai vu effectivement d'autres
d'autres boxing et notre test d'autres
personnes qui sont d'ailleurs je vous
salue qui sont sélectionnés comme moi
pour être les 50 testeurs officiels du
lion gabou qu'en france il ya des
graphistes qui effectivement je le vois
ont une vraie facilité à utiliser ce
petit outil jeu s'est dessinée à tête à
toto je sais faire des morpions mais le
reste c'est pas mon truc
par contre effectivement pour la gestion
des commentaires de mes commentaires sur
youtube pour effectivement faire du
traitement de texte c'est très pratique
c'est vraiment bien foutu j'utilise
depuis quelques jours et pour l'instant
je n'ai toujours pas recharger donc ça
c'est vraiment le côté sympa et côté
très pratique je dois reconnaître que
lorsqu'on veut le passé comme ça pour
bosser normalement il tournoi quand on
le passe comme ça il ya un côté qui est
aussi vraiment pratique quand on veut
regarder des choses on peut faire pas
mal pas mal de choses je trouve ça
vraiment bien
1 je dois le reconnaître lorsque vous le
passez à la verticale comme ça et que
vous allez chercher à ouvrir on va
prendre un logiciel paint tout con je le
disais je suis pas un dessinateur donc
c'est pas du tout
domaine ma compétence mais lorsque je
vais me poser et que je vais dessiner la
tête à toto la up up down et la mouche
là tu vois tes oreilles tu es tu as milk
et même je suis vraiment pas un
dessinateur mais par contre je trouve
que pour le coup c'est vraiment pratique
pour la prise de notes je trouve ça cool
je trouve que l'outil est bien pensé le
fait de pouvoir naviguer comme ça
d'ouvrir mes trucs de fermer de quitter
avec le stylo ou je sais pas comment
vous l'appelez excusez moi pour les
professionnels je trouve ça vraiment
bien
donc on est un petit peu ce qu'on peut
dire aujourd'hui sur cette tablette que
je trouve moi plutôt bien plutôt facile
de prise en main je dirais que le seul
défaut principal sont les petites
rayures qu'on peut avoir sur le côté
parce que comme tous les objets comme un
smartphone comme n'importe quoi qu'on va
pouvoir prendre posé bien des impuretés
sur une table ça peut s'abîmer serez y
est c'est un peu le côté négatif mais
bon après ça vient pas vraiment de la
construction cela plus de l'utilisation
et puis descendre sur lequel on va le
poser je pense que c'est un produit qui
va ce samedi mais assez assez assez
rapidement voilà un petit peu pour le
côté le côté négatif de ce projet selon
moi je le trouve je trouve bien il
semble en tout cas robuste de bonne
facture
il s'ouvre bien et réagit bien quelle
que soit l'utilisation qu'on en fait
donc on va beaucoup parler dans les
temps à venir sur la chaîne parce
qu'effectivement passé c'est un produit
sur lesquels il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à dire et puis j'ai la chance
d'être sélectionné par faire partie des
50 testeurs en france de ce produit donc
je vais me faire un vrai plaisir à en
parler merci en tout cas d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser vos
commentaires vos impressions et vos avis
paix dites moi si vous en avez testé
d'autres si vous allez tester ce produit
là si vous avez testé les produits
concurrents pour qu'on puisse un petit
peu ce faire un point de vue le point de
vue je dirais objectif
merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner la chaîne
avoir beaucoup parlé de ce produit
durant les semaines qui viennent parce
qu'ils aient beaucoup de choses à dire
dessus on va parler aussi de high tech
et de plein d'autres choses donc rester
connecté puis moi je vous dis à très
bientôt
merci
[Musique]